now in the case of so-called same-sex
marriage that actually was not the
people getting it wrong the people were
consistently against that redefinition
the Supreme Court had to impose that
from above and as with many things when
when there are impositions made by the
political order that does change Minds I
know conservatives are fond of saying
that politics is Downstream of culture
which is true enough in many
circumstances but the law is also a
teacher and can shape the culture as
well and have extraordinary influence on
the culture and that's what happened in
the case of same-sex marriage if the
court came down tomorrow and said no
actually we got that one wrong turns out
boys and girls are different sorry you
know taking an audible on that I suspect
within 5 years or so public opinion
would return to what it normally has
been so no I don't think that the people
are the voice of God and they can get it
wrong which is why it's very very
important to protect the uh just and
prudent limits that have been placed on
the people so that we don't descend into
mob rule uh by our very wise founding
fathers